[موسيقى]
سيتم اعتقالي يوم الثلاثاء هذا ما قاله
ترامب داعيا انصره للاحتجاج ومثيرا العديد
من الاسئله وسيناريوهات فاين سيتواجد
ترامب في ذلك الموعد الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دو تراب يتمتع بحمايه على مدار 24
ساعه من قبل الخدمه السريه الخاضعه لقانون
البلاد ويعيش حاليا في منزله بفلوريدا ولا
يعرف اذا ما كان سيغادره ام لا لكن كيف
ستسير الامور اذا صدر حقا
ام ترامب صرح ان موكله سيستجيب ويسلم نفسه
في حال وجهت جنائيه ولا نقاوم الاعتقال
قانونيين قالوا ان من المراجع اطلاق سراح
ترامب كونه لا يشكل خطرا جنائيا الى حين
موعد المحاكمه التي اكدوا انها لن تبدا
قبل عام او اكثر اي مع الاشهر القتاليه
للحملات الانتخابيه
وعن هذا غرض ايلون ماسك قائلا ان تم فعلا
اعتقال ترامب فانه سيحقق نصرا انتخابيا
كاسحا اما عن سبب الاعتقال فيواجه ترامب
تهمه بدفع مبلغ 130 الف دولار لممثله
افلام اباحيه قبل اسابيع من انتخابات عام
2016 مقابل صمتها عن علاقه قالت انها
اقامتها معها الامر الذي كانت سيضر بحظوظه
كمرشح رئاسي واخيرا هل دفعه المبلغ جائز
بالقانون مكتب المدعي العام الذي يقود هذا
التحقيق اعتبر دفعه المبلغ انتهاكا
لقوانين التمويل الانتخابي وانه تبرع خفي
لمرشح رئاسي يستوجب محاكمته